d'une couleur elle déduit que je trouve
vraiment particulière
pn luigi l'espace poser d'être super
bourgeois bon chic bon genre
gossas gaillot cet aspect là
certainement mais il ya toute une autre
il ya tout un autre aspect de me dis que
peut-être moins connu pire est que je
trouve absolument fascinant alors ce
soir j'ai décidé de vous sortir dans un
club existe depuis 44 ans le wheel club
tout le sort de destitution du quartier
nos jeunes le public en général et on
fait des amis qui quand que tu es on a
du fun c'est pas ça pas besoin d'être 26
mai faut que la loi 2 avant soixante et
cent et les chansons du pain cuit nous
voir si vous voulez mais pas le rock n
roll pour le vieux pas dans les autres
centres de musique c'est pas de jazz
band nous
et
andy gill c'est la capitale et aubry
hamon le plaisantin oui c'est mais ça
peut avoir avec couche converser à part
avec le lit des duos d'aventuriers
on poursuit notre visite on est au annie
martin sur la rue sherbrooke ouest
la musique fait tous les poids
on y brise les personnes qui sont dans
leur vingtaine la trentaine de 40 m et
plus qui ne sont pas allés mardi au
moins de temps en temps parce que c'est
incontournable du dieu c'est
véritablement éternelle c'est quelque
chose de pas permis à beaucoup
d'anglophones gym permettent qui ne sont
pas ceux ci ne sont pas sauvés en
intérieur
l'on nous racines les anglophones mais
les irlandais les écossais sont quand
même encore un dj dans l'ouest de niamey
alors tu nous amènes déduit le soir oui
et là on est lendemain la veille
oui sont ici on est chez cosmo une autre
institution de dvd des serbes et des
jeunes et toute la journée ou encore
cédé habituant - oui oui je pense que
oui
il ya vraiment
et ça fait tellement longtemps que ça
existe mais je me souvenais sur le style
bien devenu beaucoup plus jeune et puis
mes enfants viennent aussi alors c'est
comme un c'est une tradition
coopérative la maison verte c'est
vraiment un magasin général de produits
naturels il ya toutes sortes de
l'éventail de produits encore incroyable
un marché de légumes
la ferme bio s'installe tout l'été mais
c'est aussi un point de rencontre pour
bien des gens mais quand même un compte
titre est
il ya une conscience écologique d'un oui
complètement
star lui avait coûté des vies tel point
qu'il est revenu
c'est un endroit où on encourage on
supporte en soutien l'allaitement et ce
à travers un café qui sur place où les
parents les familles peuvent livre
brésil isolement jaser entre
ventilées sur ce que si être parole on
cherche la tâche monde constamment en
tant qu'être humain donc on continue à
faire ce au quotidien c'est ce qu'ils
ont dit un village d'actes mans ça
ajoute à la qualité de vie
tous